The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
All right.
Today we are continuing in
oxidation-reduction.
And so we started this a little
bit last week.
And we talked briefly about
balancing equations which,
as you recall,
is really about counting.
It is not an intellectually
challenging topic and just
requires making sure that you
counted everything
appropriately.
You have to be a little bit
careful doing it,
but it is really not too hard.
Being able to balance
oxidation-reduction equations,
then, allows you to go on to
talk about the things that we
will be talking about today.
Today we are going to cover
electrochemical cells,
Faraday's law,
and the relationship between
delta G and cell potential.
If everyone could quiet down a
little bit, I can hear a lot of
noise in the background.
I realize you are still
settling down and pulling out
your notes.
As I have mentioned all the way
through the lectures I have
given so far,
you have to remember all the
things you have learned because
they are going to come back
again.
Today we will be back to
thermodynamics and talking about
spontaneous reactions and delta
G.
This all ties in together.
These units are really more
applications of things that you
have already learned in the
first half of the course.
And currently we are in Chapter
12.
So, an electrochemical cell.
What is an electrochemical
cell?
Well, it is any device in which
you have an electric current.
An electric current is just the
flow of electrons through a
circuit.
And the current is either
produced by a spontaneous
reaction.
See where delta G is going to
come into this?
It is either produced by
spontaneous reaction or used to
bring about a non-spontaneous
reaction.
You can use an electrochemical
cell to force a non-spontaneous
reaction to go.
A battery, which most of you
are familiar with and use in
many of the gadgets that you
have, is really just a
collection of these
electrochemical cells.
And, as we will see perhaps at
the end of today's lecture or
next time, all these principles
that you are learning about
oxidation-reduction apply to
oxidation-reduction reactions
that happen in your body.
The same principles that apply
for a battery apply for chemical
reactions that are in your body
that are important for human
health.
We will talk about that as
well.
Here is an example of an
electrochemical cell.
This is a pretty simple
We have two beakers here.
And we have electrodes,
which are connected by wires,
and they are connected to
something that can read the
current that is coming through
the system.
There is also a salt bridge,
which we will talk about in a
few minutes.
This would be a fairly simple
one that one could construct.
And I like to joke about what
people would say in the old days
when I go and do fundraising
stuff for MIT and meet alumni
that graduated from this place a
really long time ago.
They probably say,
well, before we could even do
our problem sets,
we had to make our own
batteries to be able to get some
electricity to see by.
Your life is a bit simpler now.
You should hear some of the old
stories of what MIT students had
to go through.
All right.
This is a schematic view of
what you just saw.
And we will walk through and
talk about all the different
parts of the electrochemical
cell.
This I drew,
actually, myself.
I think actually I stole maybe
parts of it, or did I draw the
whole thing?
I cannot quite remember.
But, again, this is my
depiction of the beaker.
As I have mentioned in the
past, art was really not my
strength.
This is a beaker over here
filled with liquid.
In this case,
we have ions dissolved in the
solution.
We have zinc plus two
and sulfate
dissolved.
Another beaker over here.
In this beaker we have a zinc
electrode, and this is at the
anode.
And so this is a piece of zinc
solid stuck into this beaker,
where you have this solution.
There is a wire connecting two
electrodes.
On the other side we have the
cathode, and this is made of
copper solid.
And it is sitting in a beaker
that has copper plus two
and also sulfate in
it.
And so let's look at what would
happen if this reaction where to
run.
Over here, at the anode,
we have zinc solid
being oxidized to zinc plus
two, so the reaction is
shown down here.
This electrode actually gets
consumed during the reaction.
You actually have solid being
converted to zinc plus two
in solution,
so you have a change in phase.
And as that happens,
two electrons are generated
from that reaction.
And the electrons then will go
through the wire,
and the current will be read.
They will go through the wire
over to the copper solid.
And over here they will pass
into this beaker,
and the electrons will find the
copper plus two,
as shown in this equation down
here, and this will form copper
solid.
You are actually going to have
extra copper plating onto the
electrode.
This electrode is going to get
bigger.
And this one will be consumed
in the course of the reaction.
And so this is a little picture
over here of electrons coming
into the copper solid,
finding the copper plus
two,
and the copper plus two then is
reduced at the cathode to copper
solid.
And the blow-up on the other
side shows the copper solid,
once electrons leave,
say the zinc solid,
electrons leave,
you form zinc plus two.
These are sort of blow-ups of
the reactions that are happening
at the cathode and anode.
And so as this happens,
you will see there will be a
change in the charge.
Here we have a zinc solid
or zinc zero going to zinc
plus two.
To balance that charge there is
a salt bridge,
and you will have some kind of
ion come in to neutralize the
charge.
And here we have chloride
minus.
On the other side,
we are going from copper plus
two to copper zero.
And so you will have a
positively charged ion coming in
to help neutralize that change
in charge.
Over here, something is being
oxidized at the anode.
Anode is where you have
oxidation.
And something is being reduced
at the cathode.
Cathode is where you have
reduction.
We could write that cell in a
little bit more simple fashion.
Instead of having that picture,
we can convey to others what
that picture showed us by this
equation here.
We have the two reactions going
on.
We have the zinc reaction,
which is shown on one side.
And that reaction was the zinc
solid going to the
zinc plus two.
And this single line here
represents a change in phase,
a phase boundary.
Solid going to an ion dissolved
in aqueous solution.
The two lines right here
represent the salt bridge.
This equation,
then, is telling you one
reaction going on in one beaker
separated by the salt bridge.
This would be the reaction
going on in the other beaker.
And so over here we have copper
plus two aqueous
with a single line for the phase
boundary going to copper solid.
If you see this kind of
notation, you can envision that
electrochemical cell with the
two beakers, the wire and the
salt bridge.
And this is a reaction going on
on one side, and the reaction
going on on the other side.
As I mentioned,
in that particular
electrochemical cell,
zinc is being consumed.
Zinc solid is being
consumed.
It is being converted to zinc
plus two.
Whereas, copper solid
is being deposited onto
the electrode.
In that case,
you have copper plus two
aqueous going to
copper solid.
That is being deposited.
And the amount of zinc that is
being consumed and the amount of
copper that is deposited is
going to be proportional to the
charge that passes through the
system or to the electrons that
pass through the system.
And that makes sense,
because if you have a zinc
solid going to zinc
plus two,
you have two electrons formed,
which would then go through to
the other side.
The amount of charge that is
going to go through has to do
with the amount of zinc that is
consumed, which would also then
have to do with the amount of
copper that is deposited when
the electrons get to the other
side.
And so this is a law.
We don't have very many laws in
chemistry.
A lot of times we have theories
that help to explain observed
information.
Chemistry really is an
experimental science,
so we observe a lot of things,
and then we try to rationalize
why they are true.
There are not a whole lot of
laws, but this is one of them.
All right.
Let's just kind of look at
little movies of this procedure
of what is happening.
And here we are going to see
oxidation at the anode.
We can pretend this is our
solid electrode here.
And we have,
say, the zinc.
And here is the aqueous part,
so these are water molecules.
And you are going to see
electrons leave,
go up.
And then you are going to have
the solid be oxidized to,
in this case,
zinc plus two,
and it will go into solution.
Let me just play this for you.
You can actually see the
electrons leave in this movie,
which is interesting.
There they go.
There are the electrons
leaving.
You've freed up some of the
solid, and now you have freed it
up again.
Now we have zinc plus two.
We had zinc solid,
but now we have consumed some
of our electrode and it is in
solution.
Now you know what you are
looking for, I will just play
that one more time.
The electrons are heading off
into the wires and you are
consuming your electrode.
All right.
Let's go the other direction.
The electrons that left and
passed through the wire are now
coming down to the cathode.
And so those electrons can come
in and reduce,
say, copper plus two,
forming copper solid.
We have copper plus two.
Here come the electrons,
here come the electrons,
and so now you plated those two
copper plus two ions.
They have become copper solid.
And now your cathode has
expanded.
You have added more metal onto
it.
It has been deposited or plated
onto this electrode.
And, again, the amounts are
going to be equal.
Faraday's law would tell you
that it is all going to be
proportional,
the amount that is consumed and
the amount that is produced is
all going to be equal to the
number of electrons that pass
through the system.
Let me just show you one more
example of why this could be
useful in terms of the plating.
In this little experiment,
we have a steel spoon.
The steel spoon will act like
an electrode and get plated with
copper.
There is the copper wire.
That is pretty simple.
You can see how it can get
deposited on top of this,
which was acting as an
electrode in this case.
All right.
As you probably have figured
out, yeah?
You often will have to figure
that kind of thing out.
In the example that I showed
you, it was set up to work like
that.
But, as we will talk about,
it depends if it is going to be
a spontaneous reaction or a
non-spontaneous reaction.
If you have a cell where it is
a spontaneous reaction,
you can figure out which
reaction will occur at the
cathode and which will occur at
the anode.
There is only way you can put
those if you have particular
ingredients for it to be
spontaneous.
And so we will actually talk
about that at the end of the
lecture.
In that particular case it was
just stated as this is the
reaction happening here and
here, but which will go,
which place,
will depend on whether you want
it to be spontaneous or
non-spontaneous.
That is a good question,
and we will definitely come to
that.
In terms of Faraday's law,
it is proportional,
and that means you can do
calculations.
One could figure out how much
zinc would get consumed or how
much copper would get deposited
if you add a particular current
flowing for a particular amount
of time.
And these are actually fairly
simple calculations to do,
and we will just go through one
of them.
The first step would be to
figure out how much charge went
through the system.
We have Q, magnitude of charge
in coulombs, which unit is C.
It is going to be equal to the
current, and that is in amperes
or A-- and here is a useful
conversion for you to remember,
and this will be given to you
on a test-- times the amount of
time.
How much current times time
will tell you the magnitude of
the charge.
That is pretty simple,
and that equation would be
given to you as well.
We are told that we had one amp
for one hour,
and we converted it to seconds
so you can get the right units.
And we can find out the
magnitude of the charge,
then, in coulombs,
because these units multiplied
together will get you coulombs.
Then, step two is to figure out
how many moles of electrons that
charge is equal to.
And we have Faraday's constant,
which will also be provided to
you.
And its units,
using the conversion,
coulomb per mole.
And it also is equal to one
Faraday, which is usually kind
of a squiggly kind of F symbol
here.
And so then,
if we go through and we use
Faraday's constant,
we can figure out that that
number of coulombs convert to
moles.
And so you would get 0.0373
moles of electrons.
This is just a conversion using
Faraday's constant.
And then we have to figure out
how many moles of the particular
element, zinc,
in this case,
or copper, are deposited and
convert to grams.
We know, now,
how many electrons went through
our system.
And so now we just need to
figure out, for every one mole
of zinc consumed,
how many moles of electrons
would have left.
And, in a particular example we
had, what would it be?
How many electrons?
Two, because we went from zinc
to zinc plus two.
We are talking about two
electrons for every mole of
zinc.
And then we can calculate moles
and convert to grams using the
molecular mass of zinc,
which we can look up.
We get 1.2 grams that are going
to be consumed at that
particular time with that kind
of current passing through the
system.
We can do the same thing with
copper.
We have the same number of
moles of electrons that are
going through our system.
Now we just need to know,
for every one mole of copper
deposited, how many electrons
are required?
And that is two again,
because we were taking copper
plus two to copper solid.
We need two electrons for every
one mole of copper that gets
deposited.
And then we can use the
molecular mass to find out the
number of grams.
And since these weigh a very
similar amount,
it is about the same number of
grams.
If there was a very difference
in molecular mass then that
wouldn't be true.
These are not always near each
other.
All right.
That is just how you do one of
these problems.
They are really pretty simple.
And there are some of those at
the end, actually,
of the problem set.
The book has things in a sort
of different order,
so you will be able to do the
first part of the problem set
and the end of the problem set
at this point.
All right.
Let me just introduce you to a
couple of different kinds of
electrochemical cells.
Up until this point,
we have only talked about
electrochemical cells where
something was deposited or
consumed.
But you can use electrodes that
are inert, i.e.,
they don't get consumed in a
reaction.
An example of that is platinum
electrode.
As it says, they are not always
consumed or produced.
You can have an inert electrode
such as a platinum.
In this case,
we have the platinum electrode
to transfer the electrons
around, but the reaction that is
going on is all in solution.
This side would be the same.
This is the cathode or the
reduction reaction.
We have, again,
the copper plus two.
Two electrons will come through
the system and plate more copper
solid onto the
electrode here.
But on the other side,
the anode, where you have the
oxidation, the oxidation
reaction is happening all in
solution, so the platinum
electrode is not involved in
that.
In this case,
we have chromium plus two
going to chromium plus
three,
with one electron.
That is another type of
electrochemical cell.
And so we can write this and
look at the notation for this
kind of cell.
In this case,
you put the platinum solid
in the equation on this
side.
We have a single line,
meaning there is a phase
boundary, so we are going from
solid to something in solution.
And now here is our reaction
that happens at the anode.
And it has a comma in between.
This indicates that chromium
plus two is going to
chromium plus three,
but there is no phase boundary
between those,
so there is a comma.
Then, on the other side,
the two lines indicating the
salt bridge.
And then on the other side we
have the copper plus two aqueous
the line that does indicate
there is a phase boundary going
to copper.
This would be for our anode
reaction of chromium going to
chromium plus three in
one electrode,
and our cathode reaction,
copper plus two plus two
electrons going to copper solid.
You
will see this kind of notation
in these problems as well.
All right.
Another example of an inert
electrode that's sometimes used,
the hydrogen electrode.
Often you will see this.
Actually, in the back of your
book you will see this as well.
The standard hydrogen
electrode, abbreviated SHE.
Often you will see in papers or
in your book that they often
need to mention how these redox
potentials were measured.
And it is often said,
it is measured against SHE.
And that is what that stands
for, the standard hydrogen
electrode.
You can have the hydrogen
electrode on either side,
at the anode or at the cathode.
Over here would be an example
when it is at the cathode.
And, in this case,
H plus is being
reduced.
And so we have H plus,
and that is aqueous.
The line for the phase boundary
to H two gas.
And then you have also a phase
boundary to the platinum solid,
so this is combining
the platinum and the hydrogen.
Then, on the other side,
if you had it reacting as an
anode, in this case H two
is getting oxidized.
You have the platinum solid
phase boundary,
a hydrogen gas,
so that would be oxidation
state zero, phase boundary to H
plus aqueous.
You can use this sort of
combination of the platinum and
the hydrogen electrodes as
either cathodes or anodes.
And so just one example of what
this sort of thing would look
like.
Here we have our
electrochemical cell.
Now on this side we just have
the zinc electrode,
which we mentioned in the
beginning, a zinc solid.
And then that would be zinc
plus two in
solution.
We have our wire,
our salt bridge.
And in the other beaker,
on the other side,
we have some glass tubing where
you would have the hydrogen gas
going through into the system.
You also have through that the
platinum electrode,
platinum solid.
And you have HCl in your
beaker, so that would be H plus
in your beaker.
Here is the cathode reaction,
so you would be going from H
plus to H zero
gas.
And so as you have the reaction
over here, zinc solid to zinc
plus two,
lectrons would come
along and would convert H plus
to H two.
And the electrode here is the
inert platinum electrode.
Here is my attempt to draw
little H two gas bubbles going
on.
This is another type of
electrode that you should know
the notation for.
It doesn't really change how
you do problems,
particularly.
But it is important to know
what it stands for.
Again, this is on the other
side, we have already talked
about that kind of anode.
All right.
This is, of course,
always things that I really
like to do, because what I like
to do is go back to something
you have already learned and
make connections between
different units of freshman
chemistry.
We are back to delta G.
We are going to now talk about
cell potential,
and this is abbreviated delta
E.
Cell potential is often called
cell voltage and is also called
the electromotive force or EMF.
You will see all of those
different words,
and they all stand for the same
thing, this delta E term,
and the connection with free
energy.
When the electrons flow,
that creates a potential
difference, a delta E between
the electrodes in the circuit.
And so the overall free energy
of the cell is related to this
cell potential by the following
equation.
We have delta G for that
particular electrochemical cell.
It is going to be equal to
minus N, which is the number of
electrons that are going through
the system, times Faraday's
constant, which we talked about
a few minutes ago,
and delta E,
the cell potential for that
particular cell.
There is a nice connection
between these two,
and that will be really useful
in doing these problems.
We can also talk about standard
states here.
And the same equation applies
whether you are talking about
delta G at any particular time
and delta E at any particular
time, or you are talking about
the delta G and the delta E in
their standard states.
Again, this means the same
thing that it has before.
Delta E nought,
the nought means that you are
at the standard states.
And delta G nought is also
delta G in the standard state.
And units, of course,
are important.
When you are talking about any
kind of delta E or cell
potential, you are talking about
things in volts as the units.
All right.
Now, what those equations mean
is if you calculate a delta E
for the cell,
the cell voltage or the cell
potential, you can figure out
whether the reaction will be
spontaneous or not because you
can use that equation and look
at, with that particular delta
E, will delta G be negative?
Will it be a spontaneous
reaction?
The first thing we need to
learn how to do is how to
calculate the cell potentials or
the electromotive force,
and then we already know how to
convert that to delta G.
Let's look at this equation
here and calculate what the
delta E, the cell potential for
this particular electrochemical
cell that we have been talking
about is.
The reaction at the anode,
which we mentioned is the zinc
reaction.
And this is an oxidation.
The reaction at the cathode is
the reaction with copper,
copper plus two and two
electrons going to copper solid.
And that was our reduction
reaction.
And so now, we can just use a
simple equation to calculate
delta E nought if we are using
the standard reduction potential
for the reaction at the cathode
minus the standard reduction
potential for the couple at the
anode.
And the point that I want to
make here is that in this fairly
simple equation,
this term, this term,
this just E nought here,
is the standard reduction
potential.
You don't want to put in
something other than that.
Don't mess around with changing
signs of reactions.
All you want to do is enter a
reduction potential here and a
reduction potential here.
And then this equation will
always work for you.
And you will see what I mean,
I think, a bit more when we put
that in.
But if it is the reduction
potential, you would be looking
up copper two plus to copper
solid.
Reduction potential,
you are looking up zinc plus
two to zinc solid.
You are not caring about which
of these reactions is an
oxidation and which is a
reduction at this point.
You have figured it out by
which is at the cathode.
If you know what is at the
cathode and you know what is at
the anode, then you enter in the
reduction potential.
Let's do that.
And you can look up the
standard reduction potentials in
your book.
There is a table in Chapter 12
and there is also a table at the
end of the book in Appendix 2.
You can look up the values.
Here they are written as
reduction potentials,
and that is what you will see
in the table.
That is the information you can
look up.
And then you have your
equation.
And you will enter in the
reduction potential for the
reaction at the cathode and
enter in the reduction potential
for the reaction at the anode.
Here, you will get out a
positive value,
1.103 volts.
Again, this is the copper
reaction and this is the zinc
reaction.
The reason why I am sort of
trying to jump up and down about
the fact that you should enter
in reduction potentials is
because if you play around and
all of a sudden switch the
signs, then you are going to
come out with the wrong answer.
And one of the important points
about this answer here is,
is delta E positive or
negative?
Because that is going to tell
you if the reaction is
spontaneous or not.
If you do clever things and
switch the signs for these
around, you will always come out
with the wrong answer there,
which then affects all the
problems that you do after that.
As long as you use this
equation and always enter in a
reduction potential,
you will be fine and you won't
have any of these problems.
All right.
Is the flow of electrons
spontaneous for this particular
cell?
People are saying yes,
and that is the right answer.
And the way that we know that
is because we remember this
equation comparing delta E and
delta G.
Here, if this one is positive,
then this term will be negative
because this is number of moles,
which is always positive.
And Faraday's constant is
always positive.
If we have a positive value
here then the net sum is
negative, this will be negative
and that will make it
spontaneous.
If delta E is positive,
delta G will be negative.
And this is true,
again, if it is delta E nought,
a delta G nought,
same equation.
If delta G is negative,
will it be spontaneous?
And the answer is yes,
back to previous units.
In some of the problems in your
book that you will work on,
they will tell you that this is
a spontaneous electrochemical
cell.
And then you can figure out
which reaction had to be at the
anode or which one had to be at
the cathode for that through
calculating the delta E and
figuring out if it is positive
or negative.
Therefore, delta G must be
positive or negative,
spontaneous or non-spontaneous.
All right.
What do you call it if there is
a spontaneous reaction?
Here are some terms that you
should know.
You have a Galvanic cell.
And that is an electrochemical
cell in which the reaction is
spontaneous.
It can generate an electric
current.
And your book uses this and
will say, this is a Galvanic
cell.
Already then you should know
something about that reaction.
The other option is an
electrolytic cell.
In this case,
energy has to be provided to
the circuit to carry out a
non-spontaneous reaction.
Sometimes you might just want
that non-spontaneous reaction to
go.
And then you will have to
supply some form of energy to
get that reaction to work.
And in the body there are both
of these kinds of reactions.
Sometimes you would have an
oxidation-reduction reaction
that is spontaneous,
and that could be used to
produce some kind of energy.
It would be coupled to an
energy generating process in the
body.
Other times the body needs a
reaction that is unfavorable to
go.
And it has to also supply
energy to get that reaction to
go.
And we will talk about
biological examples of these as
well.
All right.
Just the brief summary for this
part.
If the cell operates
spontaneously,
that can be determined by the
delta E.
A positive value means a
negative value,
so that will be spontaneous.
And you can get your delta Es
from standard reduction
potentials for the half
reactions involved.
All right.
Now we are going to think about
what it means if we have certain
standard reduction potentials.
If you have a standard
reduction potential that is a
large positive number,
or if you have a standard
reduction potential that is a
large negative number,
or if you are somewhere in
between.
What does that tell you about
the properties of those
particular elements?
A large positive standard
reduction potential means that
the element is easy to reduce.
Let's look at an example for
this.
An example, we have F two gas
plus two electrons going to two
F minus.
This has a standard reduction
potential of plus 2.87 volts,
and that is a large positive
number.
What that is going to mean is
that this is favorable in the
direction it is written.
And favorable means it is easy
to add electrons.
This wants to be reduced to F
minus.
It is happy that way.
If it has a large positive sign
for the standard reduction
potential, then delta G will be
negative, which will be
favorable or spontaneous in that
direction.
This is a favorable reaction.
F two is easy to reduce.
It wants to be reduced.
Is it a good oxidizing agent?
Yes.
Again, a good oxidizing agent
oxidizes other things and is
reduced itself.
It runs around and tries to
oxidize other stuff,
which means that it gets
reduced, which is what it wants
to be.
It wants to be reduced.
This is a good oxidizing agent.
If we look at the couple here,
F two slash F minus,
this reduction couple
with a large positive value,
what we can say is that the
oxidized species,
that is this one here,
the F two,
is very oxidizing.
It is a good oxidizing agent.
And this is a table from your
book, so it is not in your
handout, but you can look it up.
Here is the page number.
And this is the one we just
looked at, F two to F
minus.
It says right on the top,
oxidized form,
which is F two,
is strongly oxidizing.
It has a big positive number.
It is at the very top of the
table.
A big positive number.
It likes to be reduced,
i.e., it likes to oxidize other
things.
Now let's go to the bottom of
the table and see what we can
say about this lithium plus,
lithium solid couple.
That had a
large negative value for the
standard reduction potential,
and that means it is hard to
reduce.
Let's look at that.
We have lithium plus one,
plus one electron,
going to lithium solid.
And that reduction is listed
with a standard reduction
potential of minus 3.045 volts.
That is a large negative
number.
If it is a large negative
number, that means it is hard to
add electrons.
This direction,
as written, is not particular
favorable.
Lithium plus one does
not want to go to lithium
solid.
It is hard to add that
electron.
That direction of the reaction,
the forward direction,
would not be very favorable.
Delta G would be positive.
It would be a large positive
number, so it does not want to
go in that direction.
Is lithium plus one a
good oxidizing agent?
No.
But it is a good reducing
agent.
Or, lithium solid is
a good reducing agent.
Lithium solid likes to reduce
other elements.
It likes to get oxidized.
This reaction is favorable in
the reverse direction.
The lithium solid
over here would be very happy to
be lithium plus one.
Lithium solid is a good
reducing agent.
If we look again at this
couple, the lithium plus one,
lithium couple
with the large negative standard
reduction potential,
we find that the reduced
species here,
lithium solid --
--The reduced species is very
reducing, so it wants to be
oxidized itself.
It wants to reduce other
things.
It is a good reducing agent.
If we go back to our table down
here, it says the reduced form
is strongly reducing.
Up here, on the far corner on
the left-hand side,
the oxidized form is strongly
oxidizing.
Down here, on the right-hand
side, the reduced form is
strongly reducing.
You will be asked about various
things in between.
Is something a better oxidizing
agent than something else?
Is something a better reducing
And if you remember these
parts, oxidized form up here
where standard reduction
potential E knot is positive,
oxidized form is strongly
oxidizing.
Down here, where you have a
negative number,
reduced form is strongly
reducing.
This makes sense from what you
have learned before,
actually.
And this is another table from
your book, so I didn't put it in
the handout.
We talked about fluorine over
here.
We talked about lithium.
This has a big positive number
over here so it is easy to
reduce, these are good oxidizing
agents.
And on the other side,
these want to be oxidized.
They are good reducing agents.
Fluorine minus has a
noble gas configuration,
and lithium plus has a
so it makes sense from some of
the trends you talked about
earlier in terms of whether
something is favorable or not.
Whether it likes to be in the
plus one state or prefers to be
in the minus one state can all
come out of these reduction
potential numbers.
And you can figure out which
direction is favorable,
the reduction or the oxidation.
Let's take a look at an example
here of this cell potential and
think about what are good
oxidizing agents and reduction
agents.
There are these two couples
over here we are going to look
up.
And that is hard to see so I
will just go back to this.
What is happening in this
particular reaction?
We have two irons plus three
and two electrons going to two
iron plus two.
Is this a reduction or an
oxidation?
As written, it is a reduction.
That means it would take place
at the anode or cathode?
At the cathode.
All right.
The other reaction we have is
two I minus going to I two solid
plus two electrons,
because it needs to be
balanced, so this would be an
oxidation.
And so it should take place at
the anode.
Now we can calculate the cell
potential for this particular
reaction, the delta E nought for
the cell.
And that will equal the delta E
for the cathode reaction minus
the delta E for the anode
reaction.
The delta E for the cathode
reaction, and you were given
this in your handouts,
we have +770 volts minus +535
volts for the reaction happening
at the anode.
And so that will equal 0.235
volts.
And so will that be
spontaneous?
Yes, it will be spontaneous.
Delta E is positive,
so delta G will be negative.
We will have a spontaneous
reaction.
Now, let's consider which are
the better oxidizing and
reducing agents.
For better oxidizing agent,
is it iron plus three
or iodide two?
Which is a better oxidizing
agent?
We can go back to the chart.
Here is the iron,
and below it is the iodide
reaction.
Which is better?
I think I heard some people say
iron plus three.
That should be a better
oxidizing agent.
Again, if you look at where
they are, the things on this
side at the top are the most
oxidizing or the best oxidizing
agent.
Iron plus three is
there.
It is going to be better.
And we can also think about
this in terms of the spontaneous
reaction.
This is spontaneous and the
iron plus three here
is being reduced,
so it is acting as an oxidizing
reagent, and that is causing the
reaction to be spontaneous.
And if we talk about the better
reducing agent,
the reducing agent is the thing
that wants to get oxidized.
And if we consider I minus
or iron plus two
which is better?
I minus is going to be
better.
Again, it is down here.
Down here, we have the reduced
forms that are strongly
reducing.
This is the reduced form.
It is on this end of the table.
Also, that is the reaction that
is happening here and it is
spontaneous.
And if you talk about the two
reduction potentials,
you can figure that out.
Okay.
See you on Wednesday.